the drug laws you were talking about
with uh steve lennon's story
the rockefeller drug laws i think it
sounds like you believe that the drug
laws are a huge source of this problem
as well
absolutely i think that the war on drugs
is the most
disastrous uh failed social policy
since slavery and in many ways is
actually just a continuation of slavery
um
it's it's cost trillions of dollars by
now
it hasn't had any positive impact on
anything drug use hasn't gone
down it doesn't there's no correlation
that any social scientist can find
between
the drug war and and drug abuse or drug
use or whatever
and it's just it's just a um it's a
money machine
i mean funded by taxpayers um you know
interdiction is a joke
it's impossible to stop it and people do
drugs they've always done drugs cavemen
did drugs right cavemen did peyote
little children spin in a circle until
they get dizzy because they like the
feeling of being a little bit out of
control right
it's just so i think you know i'm on the
board of the drug policy alliance
and you know we espouse a philosophy
called harm reduction
and harm reduction basically means first
you accept that drugs always have been
it always will be a part of society and
then you start sitting down and figuring
out how do we minimize the amount of
damage that drugs will do to the society
it's not by destabilizing foreign
governments it's not by defoliating
forests
it's not by locking people up we're
still we're still still arresting over
half a million people a year for pot in
america
there's still people serving life in
prison in america
for pot it's legal everybody's making
money
it's nuts so yeah i mean the and the
drug war
you touched on this before andrew you're
absolutely right it's always used as the
pretext
and the excuse right oh well we thought
we smelled weed in the car
or they looked like uh or we're gonna go
bust down brianna taylor's you know
we're gonna go
do a raid like we're looking for osama
bin laden because we heard there was
some drugs in the house
there's probably drugs in your house
it's probably drugs in everybody's house
i don't know i mean i don't do drugs
personally but you know most people do
and most people
and she didn't by the way but it's
irrelevant if she did or didn't one of
my campaign pledges was that i was going
to pardon
uh everyone who was in jail for a
non-violent marijuana-related offense
and then i was going to high-five on
their way out of jail
and i was joking i would do it on april
20th
so i would have done it any day but you
know
i just thought that that was like a you
know like a funny image
of me high-fiving folks on their way out
of jail
um and they'd be like wow things have
really changed
it's like an asian president he's just
pardoned a bunch of non-violent drug
related offenders and
one of the jokes i told is like those
are the folks we should be pardoning
not these like well-connected rich
weirdos
we should be parting folks who just
shouldn't be in jail in the first place
and at this point
uh marijuana is legal in a whole lot of
the country and we have people
who are behind bars for doing things
that people are doing openly
you know in colorado and other parts of
the country at this point doesn't make
any sense
uh but so that to me was like a no
brainer that
most americans would agree with uh and
then you can go up the line
i i was for decriminalizing opiates um
and for safe consumption nights and
other things especially that plague
because that has become widespread and
it was essentially government
facilitated
i mean the government just turned a
blind eye to the threat of opiates
uh in in the form of purdue pharma and
the rest of it
and and then we criminalize it on top of
it it's like you go you show up and be
like hey
sorry you're all addicted while we
turned a blind eye to this stuff it's
like let's throw you in jail like
you know i mean like like that stuff
didn't make any sense
to me i talked to folks who
swear by psychedelics as a treatment
for uh post-traumatic stress disorder uh
and other conditions that many military
vet that struggle with and
that made me a believer in the fact that
we should be uh letting folks experiment
um so that the the uh
criminalization of a lot of these
substances has led to this
overgrown system that has enabled
uh all sorts of brutal behaviors
uh and the examples you you cite are
dead on
yeah i mean look the war on drugs we
know now has been confirmed but i think
it's haldeman right um it was nixon's
aide
uh who said and she was you know i guess
starting to look at his own mortality uh
several years ago he said look nixon
didn't care about drugs he didn't want a
war on drugs
he wanted a war on black people and
hippies but he couldn't call it that
so we decided to call it a war on drugs
at the time no one in america cared
about drugs it wasn't in the top like 50
issues that
that people cared about um and so they
had to figure out a way to make people
care about it so they came up with this
marketing thing the war on drugs
and then because police departments also
in the way i understand it originally
didn't care about drugs they didn't want
to go arresting low-level people for
stuff
like that so they created these
incentives right where they would give
these
bonuses and extra equipment and military
equipment and all this other stuff and
um they created quotas for these um
local
uh police departments to to make these
drug arrests in order to incentivize
them to do something that they didn't
want to do i think they were
preferred and probably a lot of them
would still prefer to be out there
solving
you know violent crimes and helping to
prevent violent crimes as opposed to
you know just wasting taxpayer money and
inflicting unspeakable cruelty on people
who may look something like the children
you know their own teenagers at home or
whatever but but that's not the way it
is and
it's it's got to go back in the other
direction because
it's just freaking wrong it's always
going to be wrong
and then when you look at other
countries that have done it differently
the results that they've had are
profound portugal being
probably the best example of that where
they decriminalized all drugs in 2000
and nothing bad happened nothing you
know
shockingly right nothing bad happened
overdoses went down
like you know there there are a lot of
positive results uh
i i saw that data too and became a
believer
or at least a huge believer in the fact
that you'd have to really
exert yourself to justify why it would
not also reduce
overdoses would reduce consumption here
in the states
it's again it's like that uh the
question it's like are people just
worse than other people other people's
people
like that's like like you have to kind
of go there to justify a lot of what
we're doing
you know i did a presentation for the
democratic policy committee in the
senate
many years ago and i said you know i
talked about the fact that you know
what how would society have benefited if
i had been arrested instead of gone to
rehab which i did right
i ended up building a company employing
dozens of people
paying lots of taxes creating some good
stuff
some good music helped me to create some
good music that people liked it had a
lot of enjoyment
uh uh listening to um
you know it's like i didn't need and and
these other people don't need to be
arrested they need well most of them
don't need anything they need to be left
alone
right and the few that actually have a
substance abuse problem and my problem
wasn't pot
um at the end you know those people need
to uh
you know maybe give get some treatment
and and then keep it moving but it's a
medical problem it's a personal problem
unless you put somebody else in harm's
way you know if you get behind the wheel
of an airplane or you're behind
in a cockpit of airplane you're flying
around high as a kite that's not okay
right it's not okay to drive a tractor
either but you know
if you're if you're doing it in your
house
it's none of our freaking business and
i got an idea i talk about this on my
podcast a lot of wrongful conviction
right like what can you do well first of
all you know what you can do
if you're sitting here listening and
getting angry as i am again
um you can go serve on juries right when
you get the jury duty notice that you're
going to get some time
don't throw it away don't come up with
an excuse
and i'm not going to say i've never done
that because that would be hypocritical
but i feel badly for having done it i
won't do it again i'll tell you that
much i did it a long time ago
um you know and i had a legitimate
excuse but in theory in
in you know in retrospect i sh you know
i would have preferred to have gone
um but that being said you know you're
allowed a certain number of deferments
whatever it is but the fact is that
don't do that go and serve on a jury
and you can exercise your uh um
you know your rights as a juror you know
you can be you can do
what's that called civil disobedience or
conscious object or whatever the hell
the
proper name for it is but you can just
vote not to convict
if you see an injustice like that you
see a stephen lennon or something like
that and you go this is out of whack
like i'm not
i you know i can't support a system that
doesn't make sense
even you might think you know i mean i
was called on a case once and they
rejected me as a juror because who's
going to take me as a juror anyway i
wish they would
if they look up my back after that last
statement that they could just play this
recording of being like this guy for
sure
but the fact is that i remember being in
the courtroom this huge ornate courtroom
in new york city and the
and there was a hundred jurors waiting
to be called and a judge looked like a
very regal in his robes
it was a guy who was accused of selling
i think a tenth of a gram of
cocaine in a school zone right which by
the way all of manhattan is a school
zone
there's no place you can go that's not a
thousand feet from some sort of school
it could be a ballet school it could be
a secretarial school it could be
anything
they still count it and they count it
through the building too like they'll
remember that
that discussion right like you know
there was a case
not this case there was a case where the
lawyer said well you have to go this way
and this way around the corner they said
no
you go through the building diagonally
and so less than a thousand feet but
this guy was accused
it was a tenth of a gram a tenth of a
gram
it's hard to think of anything that
weighs a tenth of a gram like a pin a
little pin
ladies probably weighs about that it's
it's it's so tiny it's almost
you know it's almost anyway whatever so
that being said
um it's it's an incredible waste of
taxpayer resources
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to
yangspeaks and click on notifications so
we can let you know
every time we have a new episode
you